ce que ça joue énormément bien sûr on
sent bien ce grand bol d'air frais qui
touche tous nos territoires avec l'
élection après élection d' emmanuel
macron la présence de nicolas hulot pour
moi qu'il force extrêmement importante
qui a joué beaucoup aussi dans dans mon
élection et la reconnaissance de mon
travail c'est assez rare très souvent
quand on fait de la politique on peut
être déçu de lui manque de
reconnaissance de nos citoyens là ils
m'ont apporté cette reconnaissance et je
suis très touché et même s'il n'y a que
50 % il ya 50 % d'abstentionnistes ne
faut pas l'oublier
malgré tout et c'est aussi à témoignages
d'encouragement pour ce que je suis et
ce que je veux porter pour pour la suite
vos adversaires dénoncé l'ambiguïté de
votre positionnement
finalement vous considérez que ce score
c'est d'abord votre capital personnel
c'est aussi le cas le capital personnel
vous savez mes adversaires soit peu
enfermé dans un dans un carcan
moi ça fait des années que j'ai décidé
de bouger en considérant qu'on était un
peu enfermé dans les partis politiques
ça date d'au moins 3 ans vous avez
souvent titré vous les journalistes sur
sur mon évolution
donc elle s'est concrétisée de cette
façon là et puis on a considéré avec les
uns et les autres et notamment avec en
marche que lemieux n'était pas que j'aie
l'investiture mais le soutien dans
marche d'un corps comme un gel d'avoirs
d'ailleurs les félicitations de l'équipe
dans marche à l'instant par paris